Help me.
Welcome Morning Neil.
Mona and I are childhood rails.
We've known each other since the last
century and we are actually grown together
ever since. And we've been collaborating
together when we were children,
when we used to talk a lot and we'll
use the like enjoying nature and talking
about other animal species.
And we also like to compare
our perception of reality. Uh,
so we were always talking about uh,
what it would be like 2 cents, uh,
things that we can send,
what it would be like to be an aunt
or what would it be like to be another
species. So we used to talk a lot about
nature more than science fiction or,
or technology. We were more
into nature and other species.
And what we also compared
a lot was vision. Cause I,
I was born completely colorblind so I've
never seen color, I've never seen blue,
yellow, pink. I have acromegaly.
Awesome. Which is total color blindness.
So that's something that was
very different between us,
that I would see things in gray
scale and she would see colors,
she would see things that I wouldn't say.
So we were at the same species.
What we had different
perception of reality to me
seeing in gray scale was fine.
I enjoy seeing in gray scale cause
I see better at night vision.
So at night I would see better than moon,
but during the day she would
say things that I wouldn't see.
Also I see longer distances because if
you don't see color you can see longer.
The senators and I memorized the
shapes more easily because color,
it doesn't distract me but I couldn't
ignore the existence of color because
color has mentioned every single day.
Uh,
like in elements that are things that are
very common like Bluetooth, Greenpeace,
Red Cross, uh, yellow pages,
pink pants, the green card,
James Brown is his last name and also
these huge country called green land as
well.
So I kept hearing the names of colors and
I couldn't ignore the existence of it.
Also when you use a tap water,
like hot water and cold water,
sometimes there's only a color
code or maps, this is fine.
But if I go to Tokyo I can get easily
lost cause some maps only use color codes.
And then when I was at
school learning flags,
I had this situation where three
countries share exactly the same flag.
And if someone asks me,
have you seen a man with ginger hair,
blue eyes and dressed in pink, I
would have absolutely no idea. I've,
I've seen this man because
the only information I get,
here's the demand has hair that he
has eyes and that he's not naked.
So the reason why I wanted to sense color
was not because of the beauty of color,
but because of the social aspect
of it that it's common use. Very,
very used.
I decided I would study music cause I
thought music will not have color and I
wanted to focus my life on the
piano of black and white instrument.
I thought that will be
a black and white world.
But when I was playing music I realized
there's many theories really then
coloring and sound as well.
Newton did this theory centuries ago
and after him there's been many more.
There's many theories that relate
color with sound and actually true.
They both frequency colors or light
frequency and stone is an audio frequency.
So in 2003 when I was
telling music composition,
I started the project with Alan Mountain
done in order to create a third eye
that would allow me to hear the
actual frequencies of light.
So if we had some kind of third eye that
would allow us to sense the vibrations
of color, but instead of
seeing that we would hear them,
we would hear a note for each color.
Because red for example,
is around 430 millions of millions of
waves per second. So that's a note,
a musical note that we can't hear because
it's too high and it's a different
type of frequency.
But if we could hear that frequency
would hear a note betweenF and f sharp.
So the aim was to create a software that
would scale down the light frequencies
to audible frequencies to that
I would be able to hear colors.
So the first prototype was a webcam
connected the five killer computer and a
pair of headphones that was scaling
down the frequencies of light to audible
frequencies.
So I was able to hear a note for each
color and I memorize the names that you
give to each color.
And I had this for several months until
I memorized all in the visual colors.
And this allowed me to hear a note
for each degree of the color wheel.
That's 360 microphones in
an awkward [inaudible] sine
waves. So very pure waves.
Now we here in shades of orange
going up two shades of orange,
yellow and the yellow. So
it's very, very micro Dono.
It took me three years to memorize all
of these microphones and the names that
you would give to all these colors.
And then there's,
I'll call it also has another
or thing which is saturation.
So we have the different
levels of saturation depending
on the saturation level.
So it's very loud. It means it's
very saturated and if it's a low,
it's a soft color. And then, um, I was,
uh, I didn't play the piano anymore.
I started painting pianos cause to me
color became my musical instruments.
So I was painting colors
on top of the piano.
Now I was amplifying the sound
of the colors to the audience.
And that was piano concerts.
And my final music composition
of portfolio was not a
score but the different
paintings.
So to me each color is a note.
So I can compose music by
painting different colors
on us on a piece of paper.
When I was able to sense
all the visual colors,
I didn't see why I should stop there
cause there's many other species because
inside science scholars that we can not
sense like infrared and ultraviolet.
So in 2007 2008 I decided to extend my
perception of color to near infrared,
the near ultraviolet.
So since then I can send some more
colors in the visual spectrum.
And this means that I can continuously
extend my perception of color beyond the
visual spectrum cause through sound you
can hear much more than through the ice.
So that allows me to perceive colors
that are not only visible to me but
invisible to other humans.
But they're visible for other
or perceptive perceptive
for other animal species.
The Mr continuously extend
the perception of color.
The other aim was not to use or where
technology I went through to become
technology.
I didn't want to have a wearable device.
I wanted to have a new
sensory organ first.
I've thought of having a third eye
implanted in the middle of my head,
but that would only limit my perception
of color to what is in front of me.
So then I looked at nature and I saw
there's many species that have antenna.
So I thought that the best option would
have would be to have a new sensory
organ,
an antenna implanted in my head that
would allow me to perceive colors through
vibrations in my bone instead of using
my ears vibrations inside my bone,
that then would become
sounds to my inner ear.
So I looked at nature.
So there's many types of antennas.
The one I was more interested in was
the same fascist type of antenna,
more circular.
So it would allow me to send scholars
360 degrees because I couldn't turn the
antenna around so I can send scholars
behind me or beside me without being
connected to my site.
And then when the antenna was design,
I looked and tried to find a doctor
willing to do the surgery and I said,
[inaudible] is an antenna implant as
such, sorry, we don't do this here.
Within the antenna implants, you'll
have to talk to a bioethical committee.
So I propose the surgery to a biosimilar
committee and then they said no,
that this is not ethical
because a doctor's only
regenerate preexisting sensors
or they regenerate preexisting body parts,
but creating a new sense of color that
goes beyond the spectrum was not ethical.
And also having a new
Oregon was not ethical.
So I tried to find a doctor willing to
do the surgery anonymously and I found
one and then we did it on a Monday,
his day off.
And then we rented the room
and he did the surgery there.
So that's my head facing down.
We reduce, we removed some hair,
we reduced the skin and my head was
drilled four times different implants.
One is for the chip that vibrates
inside my head to other implants or the
structure of the antenna and we
decided to add a fourth implant,
which is Internet connection so that I
can then receive colors from other parts
of the world. Not only the antenna, but
people can also send colors to my head,
arcane connect to external devices.
So it took two months for the
antenna in my head to merge.
So now the angina is part of my skeleton,
so if someone pulls down there,
it's impossible to remove it because
it's inside my bone and I had to get used
to my new height. I'm officially
taller now, Internet connection.
I have five people in the world that
have permission to send colors through my
head. They can do it through their mobile
phones so they can stream live images
directly to my head.
So if there's a beautiful sunset in
Australia now someone in Melbourne can
actually use the mobile phone to stream
the live images of the sunset to my head.
So I could be here,
but sensing the colors of a sunset or
if someone sends me colors at night,
then they can actually
influence my dreams.
So if I wake up and I realized I dreamt
the violet people and violent houses,
it's probably because someone was
sending me violet colors at night so my
friends can actually color my dreams or
they can change the way I drink because
of the college they sentence.
So we using the internet as a sense here.
So the Internet is not being used as a
tool or a communication tool is more of a
way of sharing a sense in this case,
sharing color perception.
And also it's a way of extending
my senses beyond my body.
My brain has changed as an Mri of my
brain. Doctors cannot tell what, uh,
what is happening to my rent.
They don't know if I'm looking at an
image or hearing a sound cause my brain
reacts in the same way.
Both the visual and the audio
cortex are always active.
So I feel I'm a cyborg cause I feel that
there's no wall between the sophomore
and my brain.
I felt my brain and the software have
United and given me this new sense.
So I identify as a Cyborg,
as a biological cyborg cause
I feel United to cybernetics.
Cyborg comes from the union
between cybernetics and organism.
And that's why I tried to explain
to the Yukon government in 2004,
because they didn't allow me to renew
my passport because they said that there
was some kind of electronic
equipment or the picture.
And as this law that says electronic
agreement does not allow them passport
photos.
So I told them that this is a body part.
And then I told them that
I felt that I was a Cyborg,
a union between cybernetics
and an organism.
And in the end they allowed me the
appear and the password is 2004 with this
first prototype. And this allows me
to travel freely around the world.
Cause airports don't
usually like technology.
So if you are technology they don't like
you very much. So this is part of um, uh,
uh,
important to have it in the passport.
Now I'm applying for Swedish citizenship
because of the material in my head is
Swedish.
So my body parts of my body is Swedish.
So I'm telling them that,
uh,
I should also be allowed to
apply for Swedish citizenship.
So I'm still in conversations
with the Swedish government.
Hopefully they'll say yes,
and if they see as,
I guess each country might have different
laws saying that if you have a body
part that is from the UK,
maybe you need to have it for seven
years and then after seven years you can
apply for British citizenship.
We've had the body part that is British
and maybe the u s might be longer,
maybe 10. I don't know.
We'll see. So hopefully we'll
have, I'll have a reply soon.
Yeah. So I, as I grew
up with Neil, I could,
uh, go with Cayman experience all his
developments and there was appointed,
he was actually better
in perceiving the nine,
so he extent the precession of color.
So I kind of got jealous and I wondered
also to extend my perception of
something. And I was studying
dance and I'm a choreographer,
so I'm very interested in movement.
I in and I wanted to perceive
movement in a deeper way.
And I knew that using technology to do
that would help me because of that. So I,
I thought, what, how
could I perceive movement?
Like what sense of movement can
we have as that humans don't have?
And the first thing is, I thought
this was that, um, we can,
we don't have the sense
of a speed by ourselves.
So I use this, uh, I mean like, uh,
this kind of glove and I would point of
people. And then when people were, uh,
were walking in front of the glove,
I could know the speed of the people
walking in front of me and then, um,
was not that useful because I had
to point and people, and then, uh,
that gave me any information and I
didn't want to have inflammation.
I wanted to have a sense, like
a feeling of speed. So, uh,
the next step was to grow the tens,
phone these into any rings.
So every time that someone
was walking from right,
the lever would feel a regression on
my right ear. And then on my left here,
and then depending of the vibration
of the interval of each way ration,
I wouldn't know the spate of the people
walking in front of me. So then I would,
uh,
if I,
I had these for a long time and then
with my ass clothes it would be able to
know and what, um, uh, what speed the
people was walking in front of me.
So it was like a sense
and then I'd be aeration.
And then after wearing these for some,
some time, like just focusing on the,
on the speed,
the hat in front,
one day I realized that maybe it could
turn the yearnings around and then these
open a whole, um, a whole space
awareness of myself. So suddenly,
because I could already see movement
with my eyes in front of me,
but in the back of our body that
I feel that our sense is a very,
we don't have many senses.
It's like very close sensory,
but the bags of our bodies.
So these open a whole space and
I could feel presence behind me.
So every time someone was working was
working towards me, I could feel presence.
Who would they be relations,
uh, on my years then I'm,
I was perceiving these
movement all around me through,
through the probation to the people and
objects. And there was a point that, um,
I, I don't want that. The,
my movement perception depends
on people or objects around me.
So I thought that I needed to perceive
from movement and live with me more
universal that didn't come from people
or objects that I could be alone in the
Bryant and you still feel movement.
And then I realized that
not only humans move,
there are many things and move all
around us and in many different ways.
And the planet itself is constantly
moving and not only rotates by itself and
around the, and the sand, but it,
it moves constantly and shakes
constantly through earthquakes.
And earthquake is a massive movement
that most of the times we don't feel it.
And I thought it would be fascinated to
transforms to them's from this massive
movement to,
to one body.
And so now I thought that
it could perceive the
earthquakes of the year through
my body. And then now I have, uh,
an implant in my arm. The Bib rates,
every time there's an earthquake
anywhere in the planet.
So depending of the intensity
of earthquake there, we ration,
I feel in my arm is a stronger, uh, lower,
and I call these the size. Makes Sense.
Um, yes. Uh, that will be,
and then the,
and then when we do like,
we see these Neil distension of the
news Nealon diversities as an art.
So the,
the artwork of a cyborg artist would
be the creation of a new sense. Um,
the, so my artwork would be the seismic
sense and meals are what would be the
internet per se, this new sense that
he goes to sooner dramatic sense,
but it's a sense of what
happens inside our own body.
So we are the only
audience of our own art.
So in order to share our experience,
we create external artwork.
Um, yeah, there's always
external. How rude,
like the reveals our
experience of reality. So
cyborg art is like taking a picture.
When you take a picture,
the art of taking a picture is one thing.
And then the art of developing the film
is that another part you can either just
take the picture and that could be art
that only experience the photographer.
Or you can choose to develop this
film and share this with other people.
So in the case of Cyborg art, it's the
same. We are experiencing our own art,
which is the experience of this new sense.
And then we decide to reveal these
experience through external odd words.
Or by the way we,
we live also mean my case before I would
dress in a way that it would look good.
Now I dress in a way that
it sounds good to me.
So I decide which notes I want to wear.
If I wear this color combination, I,
I'm dressed in c major, so I,
I'm, I'm wearing a major chord.
So I would dress like this in happy
occasions. This is a minor chord.
I would dress like this,
didn't funerals.
So that's a a sad court
or I can also wear songs.
So I'm designing clothes with a friend
so that can wear specific melodies.
This is a tie that sounds
like electronic music.
So I really liked a piece of electronic
music. The tie, if I listened to it,
I hear the electronic music.
So the longer the title longer the melody,
you can choose how long you
wanted. Also, the way I,
I see houses has changed now.
My living room for example,
is painted in c major,
pink, blue and yellow.
So then when I go inside,
it's major chord.
The floor is all red because
red is the lowest frequency.
So it's the lowest sound. So it gives
a profound sound to the whole house.
Then the exit door is, um, is um,
green because green is in the middle
of the spectrum. So it gives a,
it's like a tuning fork
before you go outside.
The ceilings are black and
white because it's silent.
So if I lie down and it's all silent,
uh,
then the kitchen is a, I'm not,
my bedroom has three colors.
It's a turquoise,
pink and violet.
So it's the notes are beat,
eat and the bat.
So it makes sense for me to happen
these three colors in the bedroom.
And then in the, in the kitchen it's
violet. Violet is the highest page,
so it gives, it's uh, keeps me alert. So
it's a color that we don't usually eat.
So it doesn't interfere with food.
Food has changed a lot as well because
when I eat, I hear different notes.
So I can actually compose music with foot
depending on how I put the food on the
plate.
I can eat songs and I'm collaborating
with a restaurant in Barcelona where we
are, uh, there's a, a new
plate, uh, chroma phone.
Why you put the food on top and then you
rotate the plate and then you can hear
the foot. So you can go to the
restaurant and asked for some music.
You're going to ask for Mozart and then
they serve you the different colors.
And then you turn around
and you hear Mozart piece.
Or you can ask for some lady Gaga Dessert
and then you can hear some lady Gaga
Dessert. So, uh,
this was actually presented the three
days ago in San Francisco and we're doing
some experimental Sonequa romantic
dinners where people eat different songs.
So now I can compose music
as well by looking at things.
Instead of playing an instrument,
I can just look at different colors
and then I hear the music in my head.
And then I can choose to also share this
experience by amplifying the sounds of
my head to the audience.
So then the color countries,
I use bone bone conducted headphones or
Bluetooth to amplify the sounds of my
head to the audience. And then I can play
different types of food. Are Objects.
Also my experience of walking around the
supermarket has changed a lot because
there's lots of colors there.
So there's lots of music,
especially the aisles with cleaning
products. And that is the most exciting.
I love a supermarket because it has very,
very loud and unexpected colors
and it's usually very poppy, uh,
pop music. Their milk is silent.
So what elements and black alums?
I completely silent.
It's not only supermarkets is also
art now going listen to a Picasso.
I can listen to an Andy Warhol.
All painters have become composers.
So my experience of walking around
the moment is like a music experience.
I can listen to different melodies
and also each composer oil.
Each painters sounds different. I
can hear the scream. For example,
an Andy Warhol for example, sounds
very loud cause it's very saturated.
So you can hear an Andy Warhol from the
other end of the museum usually because
it's very loud.
Whereas all the pain things sound less
because they're less has saturated.
The way I send people as well has
changed because when I look at someone,
I hear their face and what I like
doing is instead of drying their face,
I write down the notes of people's faces,
like the sound of the eyes,
the lips of the skin, the hair, and then
I send them an MP three of their face.
So they thinking like I'm hearing those
now. The first one was [inaudible].
I asked Prince Charles if I could listen
to his face and this was his reaction
when I asked him. Each
person. It sounds different.
Judi Dench has silent hair like a glass
of milk, so she has this very silent, uh,
uh,
James Cameron has very loud
skin high-pitch shade of skin.
Al Gore has different notes in his eyes,
different shades of Turquoise.
So different nodes in each
eye. Tim Berners Lee has a
very odd sound of eyelid,
so his eyelids sound very unusual.
Marina Abramovic is very silent, uh,
almost a silent all her,
but the lips are very loud and very low.
Uh, Steve Wozniak, Zeiss, I'm like
green apples. So very bureau as well.
Moby sounds very little. She
is one note missing. No hair.
So he has less knowledge than
other people. We're the island.
Sounded like an old painting. Very
unsaturated. Metallica lugging, see major,
a major chord.
It's unusual to find major courts
where the Phillip glass sounds very
[inaudible], very similar to his music
and Bono at very, very loud glasses.
In this case he's got his where violet
and very saturated. If you wear makeup,
then you sound very different. Uh,
if, if you went to hear your face,
you would not use red lipstick,
you would use green lipstick because
the sound of green sounds very good with
the skin. So, uh, if we would hear color,
most people would wear green
lipstick and then some blue here.
Cause then it sounds see major or you
have f sharp major in the face that you
didn't like it.
No.
And then what really surprises me is
that people who say they're black,
they're not black. And people who
say they're white, they're not white,
people will say they're black,
they're very, very dark orange.
And they book will say that why
they are very, very light orange.
So the fact that people say
that humans are black and white,
it is completely false. We are all
different shades of orange, very,
ours are very dark orange.
This is a color wheel and there's a
reddish orange or yellowish orange.
And then there's different
shades of light.
I can also do face concerts where
instead of playing the objects of colors,
I played the audience's colors.
So I, I look at the faces.
The audience is the onion skews in that
and start creating rhythms with the
sound of the eyes, the hair,
the lips of the audience.
And I create layers of sound.
So it's electronic music created by,
by the colors of the others.
If the concert sounds really bad,
it's their fault because that's
where the music comes from.
Uh, the last face concert was of
Prince Albert, the second of Monaco.
He liked the sound of his face so much
that he's using it as his ringtone.
So when people call him,
here's his face.
The secondary effect of hearing
colors that sounds also become colors.
So if I hear the line, uh, telephone line
for me is green. Mostly it creates the,
the frequency of green.
And I can also play music.
This is Mozart's queen of the night.
Note by note from the center to the end.
This is also music,
this baby baby by Justin Bieber
from the first book to the last.
Also when we speak,
use different frequencies.
So I can transpose speeches into color.
One of them is Martin Luther
King's I have a dream speech.
And the other one is a speech by Hitler.
They look very different because they
used very different types of frequencies
when they spoke.
Also colors I use now with musicians.
So music has learned the sound of color
and then they have the concert colors
are projected on stage
and that's the score.
So they play the colors of that
projected in the, on the, on the stage.
And also there's a public sculptures that
use the sauna chromatic scale as well.
So in this case,
this is a song you can download an app
on your mobile phone and then you walk
underneath the sculpture and
then you can listen to a melody.
And at night it changes color.
So you can actually hear music by
pointing your phone at the sculpture that
keeps changing colors.
Uh,
the reaction that people I've had with
people through the years has changed.
I've the fact of having an Antinomians
people stop me everyday since 2004 and
they asked me what it is or they,
they just laugh and they leave. Uh,
the thing is that it's changing.
In 2004,
many people thought it was a reading
light that I had some kind of uh,
that it would turn on and they asked me,
can you turn the light on?
And it's not the light. So they thought
it was a reading light in 2005, six,
I thought it was a microphone for Internet
chat in 2007 they thought it was a
Bluetooth phone, like a taxi drivers
started having hands free phone.
So therefore thought it
was some kind of phoning.
2009 people thought it was something to
do with Gopro that I was filming my life
in 2012, uh, people started to think
it was something to do with Google,
Google glass.
It was sometime connected in
2014 15 they thought it was,
well children asked me if it was some
kind of expendable selfie stick that and
not lately for the last three,
three months,
people point at me and they say Pokemon.
They thought it, I think Pokemon,
they tried to catch me sometimes. So it
keeps changing. What people think it is.
Hopefully in the 2010 people will just
think is an antenna and as a new sensory
organ,
but it's still not happening.
Yeah.
There's one,
one way of the shine is also like
we created this siren sculptures.
One is like the three d version of
my arm and the other one is like the
immersion of Neil's head
and it was exhibited in
Barcelona and my arm would uh,
would be connected to the
online seismograms like
my own arm and people were
able to touch it. Then whenever there
isn't and there was an earthquake,
they could fill it and we're going to
like say, well this culture it goes,
it's a say a sculpture.
Can I get to a living organism?
In Micah is was the earth and in Neal's
case it was connected actually to Neil's
head.
Yeah. So people in the gallery, they
could send colors to my head life.
So one of the five connection
in the world for six months,
it was the sculpture in the museum so I
can receive in college from visitors of
the museum. It was overwhelming because
there were schools there as well.
So they were sending lots of colors,
have blood every day.
Am I one of my ways to share and sell?
So the way in a performance and it's
called waiting for earthquakes was
standstill on a place and then a
wait for an earthquake to take place,
which is very often and whatever happens,
I move according to the
intensity of the earthquake.
So it's a durational business and have
big 89 and it can last 10 minutes.
I can last hours.
And it's just a,
it's like a dual between the earth
and myself live the earth is like the
choreographer of the piece and I'm Josie
t interpretating the real data that is
coming through, it's like an
invitation to the audience just to,
to listen for a while the, the,
the natural movement of the earth.
And also wanted to say that, um,
when the first time I had to, ah,
there's the seismic
sensor at the beginning,
I had to get used to fill
this with patients every day.
And maybe if there was a big one in the
middle of the night, I would wake up.
But at the end,
like now more yesterday and,
and now it feels like
having two heartbeats,
like I have my own and then this
constant aeration, mim and I, it's like,
I mean, yeah, to be, it's like the earth,
the earth beat and then my heartbeat,
like at the same time.
And also though the space sometimes
in different places in New York,
I have these new skip and uh,
suddenly I appeared somewhere
in the street and a,
and I have a paper explaining
what I do. And this was, uh,
I was in the middle of the night waiting
in Times Square and some people lay
down also. So it's like, it can
be, it can be, it's a piece of,
it can be anywhere because it just
means standing there waiting for an
earthquake. So yeah, like when, well,
yeah, that's it. And then, uh, my, uh,
my other thing is that I do it with
percussion and then we're going to show,
so I can do seismic and I go
like size my bird question.
Whether earth in this case would be like
the composer of the, I can play the,
in the earthquake that happened in
real time through the runs on oil.
I also create a scores like that.
They look like this. For example,
when I perform the Mexico,
I research all the earthquakes at that
and that that had taken place in x in
Mexico for the last 50 years. And I
made a score that lasted eight minutes.
So during the Amia,
as I played on the size of negativity
that happened in that place,
so it was a very divided
and very, uh, strong, uh,
strongest score. So that, yeah, there's a,
the score is based on the same seismic
activity of in a specific place.
And they also transform these into,
into paintings.
This is like a hundred a
century of earthquakes in
the u s and then I also have
an a score,
but this is transformed into a painting.
Okay.
And I also lead a,
when I was doing the speed of,
of the people walking in front of me,
uh,
I seen it and I traveled around
and around Europe hitchhiking.
And the aim was to rise to every capital
and I would define each capital with
the speed of the citizen's walking on
it because I realized that depending of
your context and depending where you are,
you tend to walk faster or slower.
I'm like,
I'm amazed.
I'm for scum and movement sense that we
have like a involuntary movement speed
that we share.
So I made like a dictionary to define
its capital of Europe by its movement and
nail they its capital bureau by
the dominant color of the cities.
Yeah.
Like in 2010 and I tweeted the Cyborg
foundation basically with three aims.
One is like to help
humans to become works.
A second one would be the to defend the
sidewalk rights and a third one is to
promote cyborgism as an
art and social movement
eyes.
We've done different budgets,
but we'll talk more about the,
the following projects in the next week.
We go into Brazil and
we'll be developing this.
I have some spaces in my
mouth is something's missing.
So instead of having no normal
days Englander, we'll create a DS.
The do things like, um, we did
the prototype some years ago.
It's the grades light.
So in total darkness you can click and
then you open your mouth and then you
have some emergency light.
The case where they'd was that when I
was eating the language going on and off
all the time.
So we added removing now in Brazil,
we'll try to make one here that
will actually also charged by,
by pressing it and it should create light,
um,
in another system that doesn't
go on and off when I eat.
And then the other space is the will god
and tried to trade the Bluetooth tools
that will allow me to
control the antenna. So, uh,
if I want my antenna to move left,
I'll be able to use my,
these to move it left and right. So it
will allow me to lie like a joystick,
but inside,
inside the mouth and controls through
Bluetooth either this are the third option
will be that we'll create two.
This cosmo now also has a tooth missing,
so that's good for us
cause he has some space.
And then we'll also use
the creation of Bluetooth,
this and this case to communicate.
So we both know the Morse code.
So if we both have a tooth
that can transfer the clicks,
then we'll be able to communicate through
more scored from [inaudible] or from
Bluetooth too, Bluetooth through
Bluetooth as one. And also that this,
we might just spend them blue as well
cause then it will make more sense.
So that's next week in in
Brazil and it will have,
will have one week intensive with
16 people working on it. Also.
Um,
we created a Cyborg nest this year in,
in London where we are actually
offering sensors for other people.
The first side is that we are offering,
this is the north stands.
It can be implanted here
in the center of your body.
And whenever you're faced
north you feel a vibration.
So it gives you a sense of orientation.
If you have this vibration when you
faced north west several months,
it will probably become subliminal.
So you will feel the north without
even noticing the vibration anymore.
So this is uh, something that, uh,
a few hundred people will have very
soon because it will be sent to people
around the fall.
Um,
yeah,
my,
my current project now and
that I'm correlating with
some people that are here,
it's thought works.
Um,
I'm living like the seismic makes down
to my faith because it feels like more
natural to feel earthquakes and you feed
and then I was hiding location cause
now I just know when there's an article
but I don't know where in the world.
So these,
I will know if they are too happens very
far for what I am a very close and also
like my next,
my next project is to feel,
has an activity on the moon because we
feel that if we use internet as a sense,
we can explore things that are happening
very far from when we are like in the
other side of the plant or even in
the space. So if we all use, uh,
AVL,
Santa was census the space rather than we,
as soon as we can become sense turnouts
and explore a space where we are here
but through our sensors.
Okay.
Gimme since 2014 I've been connecting
to NASA's international space station so
that I can send you the colors from space.
The beginning it was overwhelming cause
there's loads of colors there that are
very high bid. So it was overwhelming. But
then I'm getting used to connecting to,
to the station and then I'm getting used
to receiving the college room space.
So yes is extending our senses beyond
our bodies but also be on our planets.
So in in the future we might able be
able to connect all our senses in other
plans. Also when we have three d
printers that can print our DNA,
we might be able to three d
print ourselves in other planets.
So instead of traveling to other planets,
we'll just need to three d print ourselves
in Mars and then use the Internet to
extend our senses to margin
and feel it. We are there, uh,
and even have our body there
without having to physically
travel in a way we are
doing now. This is our little
experiments of, of sensing space.
Also sharing these experiences by doing
space concerts where I amplify the
sounds from my head to the audience.
The first concert I had to stop because
I was getting dizzy of so many colors
from space, but the audience had already
left. So it was fine. It was too noisy.
The second concert, someone in the
audience had an epileptic attack.
What is a seizure?
So we had to stop as well.
We'll do a concert here now so
he will do just a five
minutes. And then, um,
well what I'm working now on with
Adrienne and Sam at thought works here.
New York, we are developing a new sense
a, I've had this sense for 12 years now,
so I feel I'm ready to add a new sense,
completely different from
color and is the sense of time.
We all have a sense of time, what we
don't have an organ for the sense of time.
There's no species that has an
organ for the sense of time.
So this is developing an organ
that will allow me to feel time,
it will be a crown between the
skin and the bone circular.
And then I'll feel different
heat depending on the time.
So it will take 24 hours for the heat
to go around my head. So once I have it,
I will know automatically what time it
is because I'll feel the heat around my
head.
But then the,
the question is whether or not
this becomes my perception of time.
If I have this for several months or
years, I might not feel the heat anymore,
but I'll feel the time it is.
So then when this point happens,
then I'll be able to modify the speed
in which the heat goes around my head in
order to change my perception of time.
So if I want time to go faster,
I will change how fast I want the heat
to go around my head and 19 theory. Um,
my perception of the time will will be
different. Or if I want to travel in time,
I will be able to just the turnaround
they keep several times and then I'll,
I'll be traveling in time or if
I'm jet lag or if I'm traveling,
I might be able to put it on flight
mode and then I might have less, um,
less jet lag if I make it travel to
this with the speed of the plane.
So it's an experiment of taking Einstein's
theory of time relativity into uh,
a sense and into a sensory organ.
And this will be more or less ready.
This year I'm at least we'd have a
prototype, which is usually an XO sense.
There's exoskeletons which are assigned,
but we also grade extra sensors,
which are sensors that are permanently
outside for a while until your brain gets
used to it. And then once the extra
sense is accepted by the brain,
you can then have it implanted.
So this is something that
will happen here in New York,
this now and that now
that we feel that Neon,
I assign books that we actually don't
feel cross two machines at the Roberts.
We feel closer to nature.
And to other animals because I fit
closer to the planet because it's very
different to know that the planet is
moving, that to feel that in your body,
that the planet is constantly moving.
And also we think that we can get very
inspired by other senses animals have
because if we experience
the world through,
through the senses that all the
animals having in our own nature,
I would spin off the plant
will be very different.
Yeah. We both think we are experienced
in the renascence of our species.
We are the first generation
that can actually really
design what sensors we want
to have,
what Oregon's we want to have.
We can actually design what
species we want to become.
We can either get inspired by species
of half senses and organs that we don't
have an add them to our, uh, our bodies.
We actually identify ourselves as trans
species because we are a greeting or
adding senses and organs
that other species have.
So we define ourselves as trans species
and in the same way that the 20th
century saw transgender, uh, becoming
normal, I think in the 21st century.
We'll see how trans species also
will be more and more normal.
We'll be meeting people with
new senses and new organs.
Some of these senses and organs
will be a known by other species.
Some of them will be
new because for example,
Internet connection is a new sense that
will only be used in certain cases.
But we'll see that we'll be able to
decide what type of species we want to
become. And that's the exciting
thing that we are experiencing now,
especially when we have the option
of three d printing new organs. Uh,
we won't even need the
electronics anywhere.
We'll be able to modify our
genes and create, um, also, uh,
organic body parts.
So the fact that we are
now using technology will
probably be obsolete in a few
decades and we'll start
using 100% organic, uh,
Oregon's new organs. And also we'll be
modifying our senses. So instead of,
in my case, perceiving ultraviolet
and infrared with a chip,
it will be by modifying my jeans.
So that's probably the end of the century.
But we are both very excited about
the possibility of these are,
we can now start to explore, um,
just when I think it's just this,
this is just something extra that
we are presenting various soon.
It's a new type of a close,
it's,
I'm a fashion show that we are presenting
in October in the Queens Museum.
It's close for the pose,
a wearable generation.
So people who don't
want to wear technology,
people who want to become technology
will also need new type of clothes.
In my case,
there's no hoodies with holes in it,
so I can't wear it because
there's no brand that creates, uh,
who this for people that have antennas,
also people who have the chip here, uh,
they need to charge themselves.
So there's a,
there'll be tee shirts with holes here
so that they can plug themselves or
they'll also have a door. And also with
design, different types, of course,
with different types of cyber.
George Wilbur's be presented, uh, uh,
in October 8th and the Queens Museum, you
are all invited. It will be a catwalk.
Weather models will be sideboards.
There'll be 10 different types of sight
words and there'll be wearing clothes
adapted to these.
There's new technological bodies.
That's it.
Thank you very much for listening.
How'd you play your colors from
space?
I am alone will be performing the
earthquakes that she feels during the,
these five minutes. If there's no worries
because there'll be no much running,
but there's always
okay.
[inaudible]
yeah.
so you talked about a few different
kinds of cyborgs. Um, and I,
we were talking about earlier there
were there these guys in Sweden,
they have like a,
we work and they've,
everyone working in that space has
implanted a chip under their skin and they
just opened a door instead
of swiping their budgets. Um,
they just opened the door like that.
So that would be a kind of Cyborg.
You're kind of,
Cyborg is a little bit different.
So I know you've been thinking and
talking a lot about cyborgs. Tell me,
what do you think is high work is and
we'll kind of cyborgs are there in your
mind, you guys think in general
there's like two big rooms,
like the psychological
cyborgs and biological side.
I think you are all psychological cyborg.
So we are all psychologically United to
cybernetics. I in many ways, you know,
there's this in language,
maybe 20 years ago people would say,
my mobile phone is running out of battery.
Now many people say I'm running out of
battery as if they were the mobile phones.
So talking about technology and
first person is a sign of connection,
psychological union between
technology and humans.
That's a psychological unit.
Also,
many people identify
themselves as being cyborgs,
but that their body is not cyber.
But they,
that's why they want to have an implant
because they identify themselves as
being cyborg.
And then that's why they went to have
surgery to become biological cybers in in
the world of biological side,
where's [inaudible],
which is a biological union
between cybernetics and organism.
There's also two types. Uh, at least, uh,
one would be that you are a
cyber because of medical reasons.
So it's not voluntarily not
have a choice. Uh, it's,
it's either also to regenerate the Briggs,
this thing sends or preexisting by,
and then there's voluntary side was people
who voluntarily have added technology
in their body in order to
either add a new sensor,
a new ability in the case of voluntary.
So I was, there's also different types.
They would be sensory sidewards. In
our case we are adding sensors. Uh,
so it's a sensory cyborg. Then there's
the cognitive side where you'd would be,
if it's technology to add to
things like memory for example.
That's not the sense where it's something
cognitive or if you want to have some
implanted so that you can
understand different languages.
That's not the sentence.
Also something cognitive.
So it's a learning or being able to
communicate in different languages with a
chip. So it's communication.
So that's more cognitive
Cyborg. And then there's, um,
physicals. I would say more about
the, something more of a physical, um,
implants.
So that gives you some physical ability.
And then in the case of opening
and closing, it's not a sense.
It would be also a type of
voluntary side word, but it's a,
it wouldn't be a sensory side where
it wouldn't be more of a practical and
cognitive may way.
Cause I think you can share information
as well with other people and also you
can then track where you've been
so it can help memory. So it's,
it's a way of extending your,
a cognitive or also
abilities with technology.
Thank you for,
it's such a fascinating and amazing talk.
I was actually thinking if my
four year old would be here,
he would be like out of his mind
thinking what is going on here.
I've been very excited. Um,
I have a question about that.
The Fisk psychologic cause by Lowe's
aspect in relation to that that uh,
I was thinking how the,
you also mentioned in the talk a little
bit about subliminal aspect after
awhile,
once he had the chip,
the sentence or the new sentence became
subliminally that you stop actually
listening or paying attention to that.
But you're still nevertheless,
you still had that sentence coming
through in some way. So, uh,
especially the,
maybe the,
the not for the light to,
not for the color to the sound transform,
but the earthquake sees firmographics
and transform maybe easier that hey,
now that I have learned that so much and
the cognition had expanded beyond the
sense or into my,
the five senses that we had.
Um,
the new s chip isn't needed anymore.
It's so part of me now that the nearby,
if skin now have started by rating even
without the chip and artspeak happens,
I'm just thinking like how deep,
how long and in general,
like how long does it take to
get that subliminal aspect?
I think for every,
every person varies in any
sense is always different.
Like to learn a new language. Some
people take a long time and some people,
some people learn it really fast.
So for me to wait a month
or something to add,
like really used to feel this and now
maybe in the beginning I would start more
lively,
more this like if I would feel a strong
innovation would have pauses when I talk
or what I've been told that um,
and now,
yeah I guess this is normal I guess
like if I don't feel it, it's when I,
I I realized that that's something I
haven't found this relations for a long
time, but I guess in any nuisance and
every person, that's exciting to think.
For example, when the north sense
several people will have the same sense,
we had really excited to see what will
happen because everyone will have its own
experience and its own way of integrating
these new sense in their own one is
I'm like,
yeah,
somewhat. If someone becomes
a cyber there'll be two,
two periods of adaptation.
When is the,
how the brain adapts to the new sense.
That takes a while for each person.
And then there's also the,
how the body accepts the new body parts.
So you can have brain rejection.
Your brain might not accept the new
sense or you might have body rejection,
your body might not accept the new
Oregon cause most sensors will need New
Orleans because we don't,
we think is not useful to use
existing sensors to gain a new sense.
That's why we reject them.
They use of glasses or headphones
or any of our existing sensors.
We wanted to have new
senses and that food,
new sensory organs in our cases.
So yeah.
Yeah.
And before implanted regionally to
prototypes or like extra senses like first
the outside and when,
then when we,
when the brain, next types of the new
sense, then you can go for the implant.
And then if your body accepts
the new material in your body,
then you've had both.
And is that a success ratio
with you? They, oh, this sensor,
I put it in as a headband or a hand.
Men and my body's completely rejecting it.
Firstly,
your brain might reject the new sense.
So maybe I had this brain rejection.
For example,
my brain didn't accept all these new
input, so I had strong headaches and uh,
but I kept it on the Indian.
The headaches went away.
But some people might want to stop
if they, if their body doesn't match.
Mine does except the new sense.
And my Mike, his body rejection,
there was no rejection of the,
of the implant material.
Nice.
Thank you.
But I sometimes have antenna
aches, which is something that, uh,
then I just pick a,
like I have headaches or say [inaudible]
and then I take a tablet and then pin
goes.
MMM.
I was curious if you, so synesthesia,
it's uh, existing sentence.
These people that are born with like a
sound and color being molded together,
they have, there's really no choice in
what tones correspond to which colors.
Do you imagine people that would have
a similar implant to you could choose
different tones to correspond
to different colors. Uh,
and then when you compose pieces of
music, uh, like it will, that speech,
that visual representation of a speech
will only represent that speech to
someone who has the exact same,
who listens to colors in the same way
that you perceive them. I don't know.
Have you ever, I guess what, yeah,
how do you define those relations?
Yeah, they didn't want to juice
the, the sound of the colors.
That's why I didn't choose,
no one chose is the frequency of light.
So if you could hear the frequency of red,
you would hear the note that I hear,
which is a microtone between
F and f sharp. So each,
that's why it's so micro tonal cause
it's the pure transposition. Um,
otherwise I would have done a
much more simple scale cause uh,
it took me three years
to memorize the colors,
whereas it good just take hours if
you simplified the scale. So, um,
it's a more objective way of possible
is as bill buhr relation as possible.
There's no subjectivity in this case.
It's just physical transposition.
Yeah.
And then the, uh, talking about
mixing it into existing senses,
have you considered adding,
uh,
yes,
sensors into nerves.
And I don't know if you can do that
without it being necessarily a painful
response, but you're hearing,
you're seeing through your
hearing,
you're seeing through another sense
nothing my case cause that what I
hear is not what this is for me.
The sense of hearing this is a vibration
in my bowl that then becomes an inner
sound bite is not like this.
It's different. And it's um,
if I was completely deaf I could still
perceive color through the vibrations.
So this is a new sense to me.
And so,
and also we don't have five senses.
We, we might have five sensory organs,
but we have many, many, many more sensors
like the sense of gravity, for example,
the sense of balance or
the sense of humor. Oh,
common sense as well because there's
many sensors that don't have organs,
like the sense of time, which is
now the creation of a new sense of,
of that we have maybe just,
yeah, five sensory organs.
But the fact that we have a long
list of sensors that don't have hard.
Thank you. Oh, hello.
Uh, thank you for coming here. I have a
specific question for Neil and full moon.
So for me, for Neil's,
since your equipment, is it
connected to the Internet?
What are the security risks of that
and how do you deal with them? Um,
and for a moon,
how exactly does the feeling you,
you're,
your body gets upon seismic seismic
activity. How does that, um,
influence the way you interpret it
whenever you perform the seismic activity?
Yeah, I feel to relations and the
separations are really, really Sarah,
like really low.
And then when I feel it,
then ninth I transform it with intensity.
So the bending of
intensity of the aeration,
the move when I created this
more intense or less intense.
Yeah. Having your body connected to the
Internet has the risk of being physically
hacked. So now there's five
people with permission. But, uh,
last year someone with no permission
was able actually to hack,
do send colors to my head,
uh, without permission.
So I was physically high action.
Actually. I liked it. So it wasn't,
but yeah,
they could become annoying if someone
started sending colors in the middle of
the night, it would wake
me up. So if this happens,
then this could be secured more secure.
But still,
if there's a hacker in this room, they
can easily find me and they could, uh,
send colors.
This is not as secure as it could be,
but like, I wonder if even just like
all, just like trying to like filter out,
um, which pat gets to authenticate
what that alone could I,
I mean,
cadaver loan and we'll even though denial
of service attack people or will you
still be vulnerable to kind of attack
even just by sending just like packets?
I wouldn't be authenticated anyway
if you got too many of them.
What does every, everything is
hackable. Everything even so.
Yeah.
Yes.
Well, yeah. And there's always the,
I can always disconnect the Internet
connection that I have this,
I can stop this, the under, but I
can stop the Internet connection.
So if it was really an eye,
I would just disconnect.
Oh, okay. That's good. Thank you.
Uh Huh.
Uh, two, uh, two quick questions.
I was kind of wondering just about some
basic hardware, technological issues.
Like how do you keep your implants charge,
how often you have to recharge,
MDF like charging ports on you.
And then also you said that you hear like,
you know, hundreds of different specific,
uh, exact colors is different pitches.
Did you have perfect pitch before you
started this or did you learn perfect
pitch from having the implant?
Okay.
And then have perfect pitch.
So I add relative pitch
but then after three years,
so yeah, if you hear color
constantly, then it's,
it's easier to,
to learn.
Perfect pitch cause it's it also in
one octave and it's in a specific,
um, timber. So I have perfect extreme,
perfect pitch in an octave, in sine
waves through bone conduction. If it's a,
if I listened to a guitar,
it takes me a bit longer to identify
the note because it's a different timber
and it comes through it.
And if it's a different octave,
I need to think a bit more. But yes,
in that activists is now perfectly I,
it took me three years to
memorize all these microphones.
So betweenF and f sharp, I have
30 micro tones. So extremely,
extremely my good Donald and the charging
aspect of of a a new sense and a new
organ is very important as well.
The problems that we have in the sidewalk
is the, I guess the power Paul Rum.
Yeah.
We would like to be able to power our
and with our own energy that the license,
that's the Yang.
I have the bag.
Let's think I can change a
small battery every five, six,
seven weeks. The Benz, I
remove it before it ends.
But the aim is to use Durbin's in
the blood vessels so that the blood
circulation, we'll charge
the, the new sensors, not,
we don't want to use external
energy, not even solar energy. One,
they use the energy of our body.
In the case of the north sense,
people will have to plug
themselves every night.
So or so they'll have a
way of judging the subs.
And also there's ways
we exploring with uh,
Orient and Sam is the judgment external.
Kyle.
So you might have an implant
was with Kyle. You can
recharge it from the outside.
Also with the toes next week it will
be charged poly with um, like, uh,
with your own kinetic energy.
So there's still ways, but it's,
that's the,
whenever there's is solve,
we'll see a boom of people with new senses
and new organs cause that's the only
parts of it that is really not
evolving as fast. Thank you.
So I wanted to thank you for
this presentation and uh,
I also appreciated that you brought up,
uh,
transgender as a topic within this
because I often feel as if I'm a
psychological cyborg and I feel that,
that it's actually a very common
sentiment among my people. Um,
I feel as if we are,
uh,
perhaps artists building the same thing
with different materials, in fact.
And so my question is a
philosophical one in that,
what do you think are the longterm
implications of a species that is able to
design and redesign itself at will?
Yeah. I think we'll have to
adjust. The net would be many,
many different types of
species cause um, each, uh,
human will make me born human,
but then we'll be able to choose and
decide exactly what sends an order is when
you have and each person
will be very unique I think.
So we'll have a diversity that uh,
society's probably not ready to accept.
The diversity that will exist in the,
in the fifties and sixties is a,
is going to be something that many people
won't be able to talk to tolerate or to
do you think then that this is a movement
away from my binary mode of thinking
and learning within the human brain?
Okay.
Yes. I mean [inaudible] going to
be on the binary do it will be, um,
there'll be so many [inaudible] we
won't be even able to understand,
um,
the types of realities that
each person will experience.
It will be even more different than it
will be evident that it will be different.
The experience that we
all have of a reality.
We mentioned [inaudible] in the future
and asking someone where were they from
there.
We also asked what sense do you have like,
and everyone will have its own own
perception or reality. That's beautiful.
Thank you.
Right.
Lovely to
do so. We'll have to say goodbye. Thanks
so much for coming. Thank you, Neil.
Thank you.
No.